make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are finally getting around to
covering fallen angels and we have a
very busy week this week we gotta play
catch-up right it was a weekend the week
of Thanksgiving and we just a famous
imperative which you guys loved I had no
idea you guys are gonna love thatis
imperative so much what happens did you
guys loved it which is always awesome to
see it's always awesome to see I can
bring you guys content that you dig but
here's the funny thing about fallen
angels right I was live-streaming to a
bunch of you guys on Instagram or those
you guys don't know I livestream to you
all directly on Instagram and like
actually bring you guys into the
conversation so we have like one-on-one
conversations in front of everybody on
Instagram and one of the guys was asking
what I thought about fallen angels and
here's the thing fallen angels is a
great story but only if you care about
psylocke right if you don't really care
about Psylocke specifically kind of like
the history of the character and really
quantum more than anything else then
you're probably not gonna care but it
does have cable and it doesn't have x-23
along with a few other characters it
looks like it's gonna be pretty beast
really like to be honest with like issue
number two it looks amazing but here's
the thing let's let's have this
discussion right let's explain the
character of quantum Kuantan okay so
sigh like explain we did a video on so I
could explain like the full thing so you
guys can check that video down in the
description if you want the full on like
30 minute explanation of her character
but but Quan Yin was man 1980s and 1990s
comics okay so a played out like this
originally all you had was Betsey
Braddock why you had Cylon basically the
the sister of Brian Roddick right she
was just like this British white chick
and that was basically it fast-forward
to uncanny x-men number 256 right this
comes off the heels of a story called
the fall of mutants and it was a way for
Chris Claremont to kind of reshuffle the
landscape once again by basically having
this great big huge set of events take
place we don't really need to get into
it but basically it led into the
introduction of the siege perilous you
guys may have heard of that term before
the siege perilous is actually a really
cool concept the idea is that if you
pass through it you ascend to the
experience amnesia and you get to start
your life over and so wound up happening
it's not like pass through it and then
washed up washed up on the shores of the
South China Sea the results of this is
that around that same time you had a
woman named quantum and Kwan and was
basically the lover of a rival faction
to her warlord right basic machine she
worked for a guy who was at war with the
tribe of a guy that she was in love with
and so when that whole thing when this
huge conflict ended up going down being
trained by the
and all that kind of stuff well this
huge conflict ended up being going I
ended up going down
she never having to basically make this
massive choice and the result was that
it basically led to her quote-unquote
death when she fell off a cliff what
this did is because she fell into the
water and basically wasn't able to
breathe and I kind of suppressed what
what little telepathic power she had
basically left her in a catatonic state
and so what ended up happening is that
in an attempt to basically bring Kwan
and back it was kind of a ruse by a
character named spiral she's not really
important that she was part of Mojo's
group kind of this weird person out
there and like some alternate dimension
that tried to treat the x-men like a TV
show basically but the idea was that in
order to try to bring Kwan and back what
ended up happening is spiral pulled of
Rouge and basically the mind of Betsy
Braddock was put in the body of quantum
and the mind of Kwan and was put into
the body of Betsy and what this did is
it basically split their abilities in
half and then gave the other half the
memories of the other person right so
Betsy Braddock was walking around with
half the memories of Kuantan and Quanah
was walking around with half the
memories of Betsy that's why when you go
into the post uncanny x-men 256
landscape you have Betsy Braddock who
looks like a Japanese woman because
she's in the body of Kwan and following
that quantum basically became a
character named revanche re v HC h e and
basically like she joined the x-men for
a little while she was a henchman of
matza rohu was the guy that she worked
for oh there were a few other things
going on here and there but basically
she was just kind of there
Marvel didn't know what to do with her
literally you go read x-men vol 2 issue
number 32 going for a really issue
number 23 going forward and like they
didn't know what to do with her they
were just coming she's there and like
she's kind of sigh laughs what kind of
not and like there were a couple weird
things that went on she died and then
eventually came back ultimately Marvel
cleared the air by essentially having
her quote/unquote killed off with the
legacy virus which was basically HIV for
mutants and then in turn where she was
resurrected and then basically basically
destroyed during the hunt for Wolverines
storyline the bodies were eventually
reversed back to the way they were
supposed to be right so Betsy Braddock
went back into her own mind in her own
body and come on and basically went back
into her own mind and her own body a cut
it was it was kind of a long-running
event right like it had taken a little
while to get to that point it was on its
way but kind of finished by the time you
got to hunt for Wolverine but it's and
so that's how you end up where you are
right now right that's the reason why
you see what looks like psylocke and
she's not actually Betsy Braddock she's
basically just quantum it's kind of
setting things back to the way they were
before now quantum Betsy had met
multiple times right in the first time I
met I want to say they actually got into
a fight with each other
it was kind of a cool little thing Maru
was trying to Tory around with it right
like Juana was powerful enough that like
Jean Grey and Charles Xavier like none
of the telepaths could differentiate
between the two
Wolverine simp couldn't pick up on a
difference although eventually it did it
was kind of a weird little thing but the
reason why this matters is because in
the midst of all this you basically have
quantum that's what we're gonna refer to
her as we're gonna call it quantum just
to kind of make sure you guys aren't
really confused but you know by calling
her Psylocke because that'll throw
people off the basically quantity is
kind of going through a whole telepathic
process you know and and the result of
this is that basically she's met by what
appears to be the arrival of this being
called a path right like a path assembly
a being that's coming now the cool thing
about this is that this is a wholly new
character right and it's one of the
reasons why stories like fallen angel is
so cool is because what it does is this
basically a fresh jumping on point all
you need to know is that at one point
along the line Betsy was in the body of
quantum quantum was in the body of Betsy
and they're not anymore and their own
they're their own individual characters
the cool thing is that what this is
actually going to do at least what I
assume it's going to do is go through a
lot of the history of Kuantan and give
you the history of her character because
we don't really know a whole lot about
her back where she first showed up right
like she was just kind of there and we
got these small little tidbits here and
there we didn't really know a whole lot
of what was going on with her character
she was just kind of there and so it's
coming it's gonna be cool because it'll
basically go through and explore all
these things but with her being met by
the revelation of this being a Provost
coming the first person she goes to is
Magneto
- basically seek permission to leave the
island of krakoa now this is why the
current dawn of X event is so cool is
because everything ties together if you
read this by itself then they like oh
why can't she just leave right I mean
none of the mutants are forced to be
there so like why can't she just leave
but if you go and you read x-force none
of them can leave because the islands on
lockdown and the AI is on lockdown
because Charles Xavier was killed no one
gets in no one gets out it's kind of a
security measure more or less as why all
these stories are really cool because
they all kind of mix and coalesce
together and create one cohesive set of
events but going to Magneto and
basically saying like I need to leave
this place like I need to get out of
here of course magneto being part of the
Council of cacoa the the quiet council
kind of one of the top members can't
officially say okay cool go ahead and
leave instead what he does is he directs
her to mr. sinister
this is a very important thing the
reason why is because mr. sinister lives
up to his namesake why he's a sinister
God and when the when he was brought on
by like Xavier and Magneto and so on and
so forth it was really one of those
things to be honest it was really one of
those things where it was kind of like
it's better to have the devil on your
right hand and nobody's doing until
let him roam free and have no clue
what's going on right so just keep him
close and keep an eye on but the idea
here is that with her basically
conversing with sinister his response is
well I mean you should go talk to
magneto but if he chose not to there's
different people you could converse with
and different people that you can
basically go to that will help you find
a way to get off the island right like I
can't necessarily tell you what to do or
I can't necessarily let you go the cool
thing about this is that he also kind of
toys are there a little bit because for
the most part since there's only real
motivation this is an important thing to
understand here sinister is only real
motivation with anything he does is the
ability to gain freedom to experiment on
the genetics of various beings who are
out there to try to just create life or
just kind of pursue his own goals
whatever that you know whatever the case
is that's one of the things to
understand here is that while you do
have all these different members of the
quiet council you do have Xavier and you
have magneto and you do have sinister
and you have Apocalypse 97 characters
for the most part they still have their
own goals than their own plans it's not
like everything they were doing before
this got put on the backburner and it's
gone forever more they're literally just
focusing on their own projects and some
of them are kind of doing it under the
radar with sinister that's very much the
case and so when is up happening here is
quantum basically goes and ends up
meeting with cable and x-23 now there's
a particular reason why these were here
if you go back and you read the old
uncanny x-men stories with with Laura
Kinney when she was really first
introduced and spent some time on the
team she gained a kind of rapport with
quantum insofar as she loved the way
that she bought she loved her style
different things like that it's why if
you go when you read Laura Kenny's
comics the way she fights the way she
moves is very reminiscent of the old
quantum fighting style you know it's
like a ninja and different things like
that it really does is really designed
to kind of follow in that mold and so as
a result of that well they weren't
necessarily like besties they were
certainly individuals who really helped
the other become better the other part
of this is cable and Kuantan actually
had a romantic relationship with cable
for time during the whole weird moment
with their character kind of being back
but kind of not up but essentially she's
worked with these guys before where like
there were teammates on Rick Remender
Zechs force I think of one it was
somebody else's x-force run but on one
of the x-force teams they were teammates
right now it wasn't really this version
of cable remember this is the younger
version of cable um the the older
version of cable was killed off by this
younger version but it's all still the
same person and so as a result of that
and they basically end up banding
together and end up taking off over to
over to Tokyo now we are introduced to a
character named otaku Amma taco is is
basically new here right like
a wholly new character brought in for
this and that's one of the things to
remember is a lot of what we're gonna be
seeing here is new she does say that
like I'll do this favor for you for old
times sake for Matsuo who of course was
a care to this long since been dead the
one that originally killed Kwan and
where she basically asked to die but the
way this plays out is eventually like
give me everything that's going on tell
me what's happening here and the funny
thing about this is that we don't really
get a lot of answers here is really like
leaving more mystery in questions than
anything else insofar as there's
basically like in the beginning of the
story you have this chick that I simply
destroyed this train and the idea was
that there's this being called a path
out there whose as much a concept as a
person it's kind of funky right it's not
like it's like a pop is an idea but a
path is also a person at the same time
who this mysterious person is we don't
know but what's really kicking all this
stuff off is something called overclock
now overclock is really the most is
really the latest iteration and various
external factors out there that can
essentially like enhance people's
abilities to a degree we've seen that
multiple times over the years right it's
basically what Mitaka says is like you
know the destruction of this train the
coming of a path is all really being
done by way of overclock and overclock
is essentially this device or this kind
of digital substance so to speak they
can basically like hype up the endorphin
centers of the brain right so we've seen
that play out in a litany of different
ways the most notable version that we've
seen is a mutant growth hormone right
that was what was used by nitro during
the event in Stamford Connecticut would
saw him blow up the entire city and then
kicked off marvel's original civil war
then right so you also look at a drug
called kick which basically amplifies
mutant powers that's why I quit inquire
is so powerful different things along
those lines right so it's just really
the most recent iteration of this thing
the fact that it's digital means is
easily attainable much easier than
something like MGH or something along
those lines but do the idea is that by
basically trying to treat trace down
these kind of directions you know where
a path is hiding from hiding out or at
least where it's operating from or at
the very least like the various forms
and you know I guess designs and it's
using it alternate Lee takes them to a
place outside of Tokyo Japan where you
basically have like all these leaves
little kids who are standing inside this
giant room and then they immediately
kind of overdose so to speak on
overclock and all of them end up going
out now of course this immediately
starts to freak out fauna because the
possibility of her getting answers is
all basically gone but one kid is left
standing and a path speaks directly
through this kid and says like my time
is coming like as mutants like go back
to your exile go back to your island do
not
stay here like do not be involved here
do not be in this place right because
the world is going to evolve I'm going
to lead it to a better future stay out
of the way or die and it's a it's a cool
little ultimatum you because it's a
great little tease one of the worst
things that could have been done in this
story is if it had just been like I am a
pawn and I have revealing who I am and
now there's no more mystery or intrigue
or anything like that you know that
would kind of suck with a story like
this is designed to to really refuse to
answer questions is really what it's for
it's designed to kind of say hey so
there's some things are gonna be coming
down the line is designed to pique your
interest to drive up your intrigue and
so it's kind of a cool little thing here
because what ends up happening is
ultimately you know what this kid kind
of delivering the message of a path and
then dropping over dead in turn once
they get back to krakoa wanan basically
goes to x-23 she goes Lord Kenny she
goes to cable and says get more people
that can join our team because like you
guys as you as you exist now you guys
are basically weak but I can make you
strong and that's a true statement right
because remember Kuantan was essentially
taught all of her abilities by the hand
and the idea is that looking at pretty
much all the other x-men and all the
other various characters who were here
while Laura Kenney is very capable
she's unpolished while Cable himself is
very capable he's a younger version of
himself not the older wiser experienced
one and so with them being brought under
the wing of Kwan she will make them
better she will make them far more
capable than they currently are it's a
huge assignment to be given you know a
huge task to really undertake here but
they'll be they'll be all the stronger
for it and given the direction the
story's going in they're probably gonna
need it but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments explain
and make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]